Thank you I'm sure you
were fighting fiber and you came down from the sky when I was climbing a cliff Did
you mean og of life
I was confident that I fell in love at first sight when I was in high school
I'm gone, I won't do it anymore Yes, Mr. Saten, I
should have thought about it a little more.
It's been 17 years old Special lecture I can't heal It's
cold Nobody listens so much
[Music]
Who are you, talk to your friends, a little Lily
This person is okay
Zena is silent
Nice to meet you Soldier
I  I don't call it an assessment because of the narrowness of the trip. It
seems like it's empty-handed for a person who accepts it
.  It's already a
two-pronged skill, but
a seat isn't the usual way of saying it.
Well, I was traveling and saw the horror in the opposite direction.
The grave of my grandfather's benefactor  When I approached a place called a player's fort, there was that star-fall, and
I chased a horse as a negi, but I could only catch
up with
it.  I had an ID card on each of the cloaks that I put on the pneum,
so I didn't have it, so
I just need to get a pack at a fixed rate.